what a year it was went to the all-star
game his first season as a national
leaguer the native of nashville
tennessee that's sunny gray and he's got
to be feeling great right now what an
incredible performance he had on opening
day on friday when he defeated the
tigers with nine strikeouts and six
innings two and two tobias got it
swinging on that breaking ball you
mentioned away
one more tough out to get here in the
opening inning the cubs have a lot of
tough out and that's a fastball with
great movement at 94. and that's all for
the cubbies in the opening inning nine
innings three hits not a single walk
nine strikeouts in a complete game
shutout of milwaukee on opening day to
come one of the top five pitchers in the
entire national league
foul tips strike three on a chain jump
three and two on a eugenio suarez here
it comes he got him on a change up we
move to the bottom of inning number two
kyle hendricks facing mike mustakas
adding that cutter there's a bullet into
right and a sliding grab by hayward as
he robs mustaches two out second inning
check swing bouncer
hendricks will flip to rizzo and that's
it for the reds we move to the third
victor carratini first up
and that strike three called on the
inside corner in 94 mile per hour
fastball by sonny gray more importantly
all kinds of movement
back to the play and a check swing he
cannot
stop his swing barnhart will block it
pick it up throw novato to that one ball
and two strikes puts him away on a
breaking ball and that's at five punch
outs for gray including the side here in
the third and the batter is javier baez
breaking ball again got it swinging and
missing not as far away this time a
great location down and away and that's
six of them now in the game for sonny
and a strike three called seven
strikeouts in the game for sunny gray
four no hit shutout innings in the book
so far we go to the bottom of the four
at the lead off walk and the batter is
mike moustakas
and a high fly ball into right field
welcome back mike moos
and look at the grounds crew down there
they came prepared for the moose's
return oh doctor having that guy back in
the lineup a little different look
that ball hit hard and a diving stab by
chris bryant for the out that's out
number one ground ball to third behind
the back foul where bryant straightens
up long throw gets him and that ends the
enemy ray is not allowed to hit he has
struck out seven he's not walked about
her
that ball drilled into right center
field and scenzel had him shaded that
way that exit velocity was a hundred and
four miles per hour
oh boy
line drive castellanos is there same
exit velocity as the man in front of it
contreras both at 104 miles per hour and
both of them very loud outs this will be
the first hit of the game for chicago
to the left center field gap off the bat
of ian half
three good swings in this inning against
sonny gray
but this should take care of him in the
inning and a ground ball back up through
the middle well now they're loaded for a
eugenio suarez what a difference a
four-run lead would make against this
cub offense and this is going to loop
into center field to base it able to
score galva sakiyama right behind him
and it is a two-run single for au rainio
suarez so he got his first hit last
night his first two knocked in tonight
mike hit a two-run home run to break a
scoreless game in the fourth the rebs
have tacked on two more here in the
fifth to chase kyle hendricks who had a
complete game shutout his first time out
and they're loaded again with only one
out for nick castiano's
high fly ball into deep left center
field castellanos a grand slam against
his former team and the reds have kicked
in the door a six-run fifth inning
that'll bring up nick senzel with two
away here in the fifth inning cincinnati
up eight to nothing
high fly ball by senzelle will back up
schwarber to the wall and it's out of
here for senzelle sends out his first
hit
home run run
nothing cincinnati
[Applause]
he swings at a pitch in the dirt and
that will
do it nine-nothing red legs sonny gray
goes back to work here in the sixth
against the cubs a team he has held to
just one hit
and that strike three a fastball at 94
miles per hour
and there's another called third strike
now going for his 10th strike out of the
game and looking for
three strikeouts in the inning and there
it is he went around yes sir and that's
ten punch-outs begins the seventh
nine-nothing lead he has ten strikeouts
killing up one measly hit
strike three call good morning good
afternoon and good night to almora punch
out number 11. and the night is over for
sonny gray he just threw his 90-second
pitch of the game he gives up one hit
punches out 11. maples will now face
winker
and that one
right by chris bryant going to bring in
a run that eluded brian down there at
third base and the reds get a run back
and send zell jumps all over one and
hooks it down the line
castellanos will score
[Applause]
and that is another walk for dylan
maples
he has walked
four of the six
batters and his night is over and now it
is 12 to five cincinnati
that is a diving stop for brian he'll
step on third throw to first
oh he caught it is that a triple play
that's a triple play a triple play
if you can't review it then it's a
triple play to win the inning it is a
triple play it's not reviewable
short right field and that's the old
ball game the reds and a four game
losing streak